bonjour je me présente je m'appelle
Florient marieus et je suis coach
sportif depuis 7 ans alors aujourd'hui
on sait que après les fêtes on a
tendance à faire quelques petits écarts
c'est pour cela que je vais vous
présenter trois exercices
polyarticulaires donc ça veut dire qu'on
recrute plusieurs articulations qui vont
vous permettre justement de puiser dans
les réserves et brûler un petit peu les
[Musique]
graisses alors je vais vous présenter le
premier exercice l'exercice des squat
que tout le monde connaît c'est un
exercice qui va va vous permettre de
bien solliciter les membres inférieurs
où on va venir placer les pieds largeur
des hanches les orteils légèrement vers
l'extérieur et on va pousser tout
simplement les fesses vers l'arrière en
faisant une flexion de jambes comme si
on voulait s'asseoir sur une
chaise pour le deuxième exercice je vais
vous présenter cette fois-ci l'exercice
des fentes un exercice aussi
incontournable qui vous permet toujours
de travailler sur les membres inférieurs
oou là on va avoir un pied devant
l'autre et l'objectif ça va être de
fléchir sur la jambe arrière pour
approcher le genou vers le sol on fait
toujours bien attention à garder le
corps bien droit et de bien engager les
[Musique]
abdominaux pour le trème exercice cette
fois-ci on va parler du développer
couché cet exercice va vous permettre de
solliciter les muscles supérieurs du
corps donc là on va engager
principalement la poitrine les pecs mais
on va aussi avoir les épaules et les
bras il faudra tout simplement
s'allonger sur un banc essayer de
retenir et freiner la descente pour
approcher la barre vers la poitrine et
ensuite on vient pousser vers le
plafond voilà maintenant que je vous ai
présenté ces trois exercices n'oubliez
pas les facteurs essentiels qui sont la
récupération l'alimentation et
l'hydratation surtout prenez soin de
vous